I gotta bring this up because we were
watching this in the greenroom right
before we got it
David Arquette is wrestling yeah did you
know this yeah David Arquette's blood
yeah
got a light bulb smashed on his head
mm-hmm cuts all over his face I [ __ ]
two-by-four oh yeah well there's what
usual isn't 2x4 yeah what is the worst
[ __ ] you ever gonna hit with a guitar a
guitar
oh that's honky-tonk right I was a real
guitar that's really surprising to me
because it always appeared like the
honky tonks guitar was just an exploding
they all were after that what is this
WCW World Heavyweight Champion David
Arquette we met wait a minute what it
was a highly controversial moment
heavyweight champion how much does he
weigh this was 40 40 yards he he is
definitely built way bigger he's way
thicker than he's ever been before
because when they showed him on TMZ he
was rolling around he looked Jack he's
got Davis eyes now find the video the
the TMZ video because it's kind of
[ __ ] hilarious it is really and just
goes to show you what happens over you
know it's a lust that you get for it you
know wrestling I mean I hated wrestling
growing up hated it cuz your dad because
my dad did it and he was never home so I
blamed wrestling for him never being
home mmm bottom line you can give a [ __ ]
about kids except those they could rape
and look at that hit in the head oh
Jesus Christ
that guy stabbed him in them gouging
yeah with with a fluorescent light bulb
that he just shattered
by the way you can get that dust in your
eyes oh yeah look how big he is our kid
was never that big before he's looking
like an Eddie Guerrero right there you
know kind of a marital arias what got
jacked is the cool thing about David
doing this is that like he just got
sober a few years ago and he's doing
this to keep life exciting for him you
know what I mean and I said why he's
doing it just doesn't have any movie
rules coming in now he's
it's okay ezel do it how do you know
he's okay you would use agent well I
went no but he's a jerk who's [ __ ]
jack dude I mean I'm very impressed with
his physique I got into executive
producing a bunch of stuff like he's one
of the executive producers of like
Cougar Town these with his ex-wife yeah
all these massive runs back in and get
stomped
I like that would you see where you just
looking pushes back for you guys gives
no I'm gonna lay down here I'm gonna get
hit again
oh and then he just hit him with a chair
that is broken clasp on it this is some
high level production 450 people in the
room yeah exactly so the blood and
everything Jesus Christ
folks a glass and the rain is brilliant
yeah that is crazy
now that's Vinny leaves to [ __ ] run
yes you could tell he's pissed he can go
the way he wanted it to yeah do you
think he's pissed yeah he was pissed do
you think they planned that somebody
[ __ ] him somewhere in there yep [ __ ]
you think so yeah could you see the M
going for the guy uh-huh
then the guy just took him over yeah in
this store didn't get back going him he
wasn't expecting that he thought he was
going up uh and then you see him then
you seemed just [ __ ] get up and you
[ __ ] storm out of the [ __ ] ring
why didn't you stay and she gets [ __ ]
ass obviously you can't see he's trying
to get to him he the guy won't [ __ ]
let him now watch guy takes him over and
he's on top of me he's looking him for
the one two three he got the one two
three see he did not want that [ __ ]
happen i watch this just gets up [ __ ]
I'm going home
yeah right now that's interesting
because you see this from the eyes of
professionals I see this from the eyes
of a layman in the crowd and I don't see
that that's fascinating you see a double
cross oh yeah that's double cross
that's why I got the quick 1 2 3 count
on him yeah you know like David Arquette
sitting back knowing that jake the
snake' is doing commentary on his match
how David get a day job and register
over a year outrageous listen he just
needs to practice yeah young buck me